hundreds of kilometers from the nearest
front line fighting the Western city of
leviv has largely escaped the worst of
the destruction suffered by other
Ukrainian cities until now
this quiet residential and college
neighborhood blasted by a missile strike
as many people stayed in their
Apartments instead of seeking shelter
despite an air raid warning being
enforced
the Russians say they are bombing
military targets but they hit peaceful
houses people were sleeping how could
they do it
rescue crews worked through the night
pulling the injured from under the
rubble
the city says it's the biggest attack on
civilian buildings since the start of
the war
we're now digging through the rubble
there are wounded and dead this is the
Russian World visiting leviv as you can
see their ultimate goals to destroy the
Ukrainian Nation but we will win we will
overcome first light brought home the
full extent of the destruction and the
cleanup continued through the day
the Ukrainian military says a total of
10 missiles were fired towards Western
Ukraine from Russian ships and
submarines in the Black Sea seven were
apparently shot down but others got
through with fatal consequences Robert
McBride Al Jazeera Keith